мамонт ще момент вже він увальня
жалоба на поминальній службі в ммов
реальної церкви кайзера Вільгельма у
берліні на екуменізм службу забралася
amoi ж 1000 людей з рідних кінці раку
меркель федеральний президент гаук
то багата на праведних німецьких політиків
[музика]
вище за кілька кілометрів злетіти символ
берліна бранденбурзька брама
підсвічується кулером вони матері
прапора раніше так не мати коштувати
обумовлювало свою петром до українців.
залишалося жертвам ця ruru
тпр метою став сам берлін ми не здається
тюлю даному а гаїті в б ти клин між
нами ж вимити його неприпустимо вигадала
про 1000 power in pussy додому моя данина
котелок і тіла від ми ви вирішила за
позбудьтеся а ти поясни у всіх цех на
подіум та побачила ще slide продовжу у
цієї ж ти нормальним же team цінні
краще і врятуй просто стоять і таким
злачному повернулися озвучкою на вижити
берлінці мені так просто
місця стане висотою і тривогою і дози в
ногу з планово відразу
якщо вона потім відпустила на волю
вирвався, що винними їх буде і в машині
жадібних серед днк пару хута що еліас
правді ми не виключаючи мощі трапилося у
знайду в бігах цьому ми дали розслідуємо
вона повних обороту туристи ісламської
держави не побуту взяв і носи ж ви
побачили і за на під цим водних видів
фото з місця падіння прилюдно вояку на
рублі ці зазвучати теж злітається поки
на піт віджет правому фронті провели рейд
біля промислу розуму районі на бенкет ночі
берліна там будемо то бачіли
припарковану викрадено want оживання
поліція за клікаючи зал і хитайся курними
і на вигляд [ __ ] ти профі дозріла